gilles rémy et ont directement ce
journal il est entrepreneur et expert en
commerce international
bonjour j'ai la réveiller merci de
répondre à nos questions combien de
points de pib on pourrait perdre avec
cette crise économique que ce soit la
france où les autres pays du g7 voire du
g20 on a très difficile de faire des
projections quand on n'a aucune
référence
la crise de 29 la clis 2288 et aider des
crises financières qui ont des
répercussions sur l'économie
et là nous avons une crise un blocage
complet de la sphère important de la
production de l'économie est en même
temps une crise financière qui est là à
d'autres courses
les analyses les analystes entre les
pompiers ceux qui sont optimistes et
ceux qui le sont moins
prévoit en tout cas pour pour l'europe
une baisse de 5 à 15 % du pib ce qui
serait effectivement une des plus
grandes crises économiques qu'on ait
connu justement vous avez parlé de 88
ans et ya eu aussi 29
il ya eu de 1873 également le crash
pétrolier quelle forme pourrait prendre
cette crise économique est ce qu'on doit
redouter une crise boursière bancaire
plus grave encore
oui la cuisse de financière très
certainement mais peut-être que nos
banques sont plus solide qu'elle ne
l'était il ya il ya un peu plus de dix
ans la vraie difficulté la vraie
question c'est l'arrêt de deux ou la
baisse de la production avait
aujourd'hui on peut considérer que si on
enlève le secteur agricole on est à peu
près à 50 % de la de production
d'activité économique donc on a une
chips qui est pratiquement de 50% hors
cub agricole on a une situation qui va
être très contrastées on peut imaginer
que les grandes sociétés vont pouvoir
faire face puisque on voit bien que
la banque la banque centrale européenne
va acheter de racheter des obligations
dont quelles nouvelles n'auront pas de
problèmes de refinancement
en revanche tout tissu industriel
économique constitué par les blés pme et
je parle même pas de toutes petites
entreprises vont souffrir terriblement
pas de recette comment peut-on payer les
salaires en mars et a fortiori en avril
quel va être le rôle des banques est ce
que les banques ont vraiment prêter à
risque à des pme même s'il est à la bb
pays peut se porter garant au parti donc
on arrive on a un vrai risque de blocage
un blocage qui existe déjà il ya
beaucoup de directions financières de la
grande entreprise qui ont décidé de ne
plus payer pour l'instant les trains 10h
donc s'il n'est pas payé ou payez pas
votre propre fournisseur
donc c'est débile principale menace pour
les semaines à venir les mois à venir
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à du
chantage damas ag le crains je crains
bien sûr puisque s'il n'y aura pas de
licenciements dans cette période de
contingentement on ne pourra pas le
l'état ne pourra pas empêcher
effectivement que les entreprises qui
n'ont plus de 2 des recettes la licencie
et je pense qu'on aura effectivement les
conséquences seront terribles dans
certains secteurs de l'économie
effectivement dont crise sociale après
avec crise économique de suivre
justement cette crise économique est ce
qu'elle peut redistribuer les cartes de
la mondialisation et le capitalisme à
outrance emmanuel macron dans son
allocution du 12 mars avait dit je cite
il faudra interroger le modèle de
développement dans lequel s'est engagé
notre monde depuis des décennies oui
alors là on a à la fois le rôle des
états et donc évidemment que les pays
qui les lie tous les gouvernements dont
devront revenir à plus de souveraineté
et de souveraineté économique voire même
politique
on voit bien la défaillance de l'union
européenne dans les circonstances
actuelles et au plan économique
effectivement nous dire aujourd'hui tout
le monde cinq ans
dire qu'on ne peut pas dépendre de la
chine pour la production de deux
composants de nos de nos médicaments
et puis plus largement le capitalisme il
est il est très pragmatique qui sera il
saura s'adapter mais ce que nous avons
vécu avec ses chaînes de production
c'est un approvisionnement éclaté dans
le monde entier effectivement ce n'est
plus ce n'est plus tenable
quant à virus ce qui est qui n'est pas
la plus grande catastrophe humanitaire
arrive à bloquer toute l'économie de la
planète
on voit bien qu'on est arrivé à un
système qui n'était plus qu il était
plus jeune alors oui il y aura beaucoup
de remises en cause très certainement au
niveau des entreprises des grandes
entreprises et également par nécessité
pour les gouvernements puisque je crois
que ne pas en parler de mes problèmes
sociaux à venir il faudra apporter
d'amendé réponse reste à m'en parle de
gouvernement à une fois l'épidémie est
terminée est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à
des changements de gouvernance majeure
telle ville quel visage par exemple vous
voyez pur pour l'europe
moi je crois que le très clairement on
voit bien la situation
la situation en italie qui était
certainement un des pays les plus pro
européen qui était de les pays
fondateurs
on voit bien aujourd'hui ce sentiment
d'abandon vire les pays les peuples ont
besoin de protection et en italie très
clairement on a compris que c'était pas
bruxelles et que c'était et que
d'ailleurs ils sortent en senti
abandonné par tout le monde
donc effectivement le en plus de la
gestion de 2,2 delà de la commission
européenne et pas du tout au niveau
c'est paco la priant de la commission se
lave les mains et en chantant du
beethoven on confine au ridicule et ça
pose un vrai problème de crédibilité
pour moi toute la construction
européenne telle qu'elle a été fait
jusqu'à présent
donc je pense effectivement curé
mise par une remise à plat de ce
fonctionnement en europe des relations
qu'il y aura entre pays européens
et puis on doit sortir des choix
idéologiques on doit être effectivement
aujourd'hui dans le pragmatisme on voit
bien que dans cette situation de crise
la réponse mais et les nationales ce qui
n'exclut pas des coopérations
internationales et est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre également à une crise au
niveau des mobilières alors l'immobilier
il y a simplement c'est que l'ia tôt il
ya beaucoup d'argent
il ya beaucoup d'argent et cet argent
sera devra s'investir
ce qui n'est plus investi en bourse
devra certainement s'investir ailleurs
donc je ne pense pas véritablement à une
crise de l'immobilier
d'autant que même si les prix ont
considérablement augmenté à paris
notamment dans les grandes villes
on n'est pas au niveau de ce qui est
d'aider des prix qui peuvent être ceux
de londres par exemple
donc je pense qu'il pourrait y avoir
certainement les prix cesseront
d'augmenter le jeu je n'imagine pas une
crise de l'immobilier
merci j'ai pleuré mais d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
entrepreneur et expert en relations
internationales